hey guys what's up I'm Alana and I'm
going to be vlogging my experience of
working for IGN at e3 2016 it is day one
of e3 right now and we are at our war
room which is basically where everyone
works from for the most part and we are
just about to jump right into the EA
press conference this is Dan Reicher
john-boy all right and I don't they the
makeup thing that's weird
does the first time I'm asked this on
camera now yeah how does this feel it's
gooey and it smells weird and a good way
like a why maybe I'm not like offended
by it and this is chemically
hi dice in collaboration with motive
we're building on the
that is the EA conference wrapped up I
am now heading straight to EA play to
hopefully play some of the games we saw
okay so I just left uh a play where I
have various classes to go play games
that later this week with deployment
times it's all very organized and looks
awesome it's now but does the press
conference time let's go
so the best press conference just
wrapped up highlights to me would
definitely fall out in BL which I'm just
about to go play at the showcase as well
as pray and quake which I was totally
surprised by I didn't expect either of
those so it was a really really good
conference again this year
good morning everyone it is the start of
day two of press conferences and this
morning I am in kind of a rush to head
to youtube live I'm actually hosting the
official YouTube stream or I'm a guest
I'm not hosting it Geoff Keighley is
hosting it that's why I'm currently
wearing more makeup that I think I have
worn in several years but it's a huge
day ahead I'm really hoping that we see
some sea of Biebs gameplay that's like
the number one thing that I want so
hopefully we will see that there let's
go
and that's Microsoft done I have coffee
I now have to go to the war room because
I'm actually gonna be writing stuff for
the Ubisoft conference which starts in a
couple of hours thank God for the coffee
sorry I couldn't really film inside
YouTube live the setup didn't really
allow that but
so we just wrapped up Ubisoft I now have
to walk to an interview with Todd
McFarlane the creator of some of the
title to toys to check those out I did
pub info for that meeting that I was
like publishing the videos onto IGN's
YouTube and main website and it was very
stressful
okay I just finished in two and tell
them falling about titanfall toys I'll
leave a link to that one below when it
is published I still haven't gotten a
chance to play titanfall 2 because it
was too busy P yesterday so hopefully
some other time during a week it looks
awesome
so we are just about to start the
PlayStation press conference at the
studio behind us
this is Monty this is Brian hi we're
very excited to talk about PlayStation
stuff we have to be very quiet right Shh
there's a broom here what so that's good
that's a hint towards what Sony's
elements its brooms so we just
officially finished watching the
PlayStation 4's conference and we're
about to record our live poster right
now
that was amazing guys what did you think
of the press conference [ __ ]
incredible curse yes [ __ ] [ __ ] that
is [ __ ] tell everyone [ __ ] nut [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're some [ __ ] amazing there's
probably the best video game press
conference ever apparently Brian altano
really liked it um that's the impression
that I guess I am now at a ubisoft off
your hours event on Sunday night I am
super tired it is 10 p.m. I've been
walking since well I've been awake since
7 a.m.
flat out walking I'm exhausted but I
just got to see some more of South fog
so I'm going to write a preview of that
tonight in Volvo's tomorrow 10:00 and
then I'm going to be on the show floor
so we're going to actually get into e3
it's very exciting
so I am now at the Xbox booth on the
show floor at e3 I have an appointment
for something that is unannounced which
means it's probably going to be for the
horizon 3 or Dead Rising I don't know I
have a behind-closed-doors preview of
that so I won't be able to film in there
but I'm kind of hoping it spawns of
horizon I really love that franchise and
it's in Australia so that is super
exciting
oh yeah it was for summarizing three
that I just saw basically that
appointment was so that I can talk about
it on combos that we do at IGN and also
on foot house on lockdown xbox podcast
it's a very very pretty game and Oh
check this out
the IGN booth so we are in the back room
of the IGN move onshore flow right now
this is basically set up so that people
after they leave their appointments can
come right we have Miranda here writing
about something we have Andrew over here
it means what are you writing when
Andrew oh I'm reading about days dawn
Jane's mom oh sorry game Babs real last
night by something Ben did you get to
play it I did not but I'm walking away
yes all right yeah figuration yes this
room is basically has Wi-Fi for us and
charges so that instead of running to
the war room after appointments we can
come in here write stuff really quickly
have some more to have something to eat
and then run to another appointment it's
it's very organized you just wrapped up
day one on the show floor and we now
come back here to film combos right
which is card word for conversation code
word that's an abbreviation that's an
abbreviation for conversation you just
actually me I did this actually thank
you so basically we have conversations
about stuff that we played this is one
of my like favorite formats of videos on
IGN and I will link below to all of the
combos that I'm in this yep
I just invaded our headquarters now look
we now have pepperoni sunglasses and
people are walking around with pepperoni
scoffs hey chesty show me you let a
grand nose Maya say they also brought
pizza so I should mention that it's
pretty fabulous
I feel so fabulous and so myself right
now
I've just been pulled away from my
writing to do a rewind trailer of South
Park basically the way that we do T's is
if a huge trailer comes out they want
someone to commentate over it they pick
someone who knows something about that
game when I was a lot about the
franchise I am a giant South Park fan so
I'm going to be commentating over the
South Park trailer from e3 2016 so as
part of e3 we have to shoot tons of news
videos and this is where we should go
so right now I've just been pulled to
shoot a news video about Xbox 1s that
slim console and we basically have to
turn off the lights for everyone in the
background and turn on these huge lights
in front so that this everything kind of
looks like the same as it data in the SF
Studio so it's these two so we just
finished riding up a bunch of articles
from something I stole today and
stuffing X with pictures of today that's
James polka and now we're going to a
Sony mixer which would be like a drinks
thing for networking purposes
which is just around the corner yeah you
three days are very long all right stay
two of actual III I'm pretty hungover
because after the Sony thing last night
we ended up going over an expunged as
well so a bust hungover day of III 2016
I feel like I've done a pretty good job
of lasting this long the first thing I'm
going to do right now
because I don't have appointments until
noon
is go and plays ello or try to play
Zelda apparently the line for most
people is like several hours long but we
have like booked group interviews for
sorry group sessions for IGN so that
people can go because we do a game of
show so people can go so that they can
vote the game of show and I think we
have one of those with a group of people
coming up very very soon so I'm gonna
try and jump in on that so I can check
out Zelda
something I'm very excited about right
now he's checking out Batman Arkham vo
that was one of my like highlights of
all press conferences was finding out
the Batman is coming to be off so I'm
going to check that out and probably not
gonna be able to show you any gameplay
on what it looks like in the room behind
we spent today tricking I was spent
today checking out a whole bunch of the
show floor taking photos for slideshows
which you put up on the side of like the
coolest boots and stuff that have been
around and then running back to the wall
room to film combos of stuff that I
played like Zelda and Batman and right
now we're about to see it's gotta fall
there you go it kind of came in at the
end so gotta for this one is for our
game of show awards consideration we
made an appointment for a whole lot of
IGN employees to see it and I'm actually
going to be one of the people handing
out a one so that's super exciting
really also been playing horizon zero
dawn and the Last Guardian in the Sony
media area and it's now 6:20 p.m. that
was Terry I am so so tired but we have
an IGN party tonight uh-huh so that's
why we're headed now get some food and
then go to the party okay stay three we
had our IGN party last night which was
awesome I'm surprisingly not that
hungover but today is my biggest day so
I think I'm probably going to be falling
apart
pretty soon first things first I have to
hand out our awards for game of the shot
so I just got to check out Crash
Bandicoot on Skylanders that was awesome
playing as crash in skyline is the
coolest thing ever so that was my first
gameplay appointment up today and now
I'm just about to do an interview with
PlayStation Austrailia just for the
social channels of talking though about
the Last Guardian and PlayStation VR and
all that kind of stuff in one of the
awesome PlayStation meeting rooms the
setup is so cool just briefly made it
back to the war room going to upload the
pictures that I took of slide shows
yesterday to get that article up in time
did not have time to do really any
riding yesterday and then I'm gonna go
play recall and see thieves so we're on
the last day I'm so freaking tired I'm
dying which is why I'm not very animated
anymore
but uh basically trying to spend the
rest of today playing stuff that I
haven't played yet stuff that I want to
talk about in podcast so I want to be
able to like you know form an opinion on
because I'm excited about them so that's
what my foes day is mostly dedicated to
we're just about to play sea of thieves
on the show floor it's very exciting
that's monte sleeping a lot of do you
like dragons that's that's Brian and
that's an Andrew down the in that it's
very exciting this is a pirate game so
this is the IGN pirate squad and
everything's going to go terribly and
also yes we really like ragging
so we played sea of thieves it was
awesome I then got some time with Rico
and just go to start writing my sky
ladies preview and now I'm going to go
and play several hours of oculus games
for my last appointment
so I ended my afternoon off to oculist
by going to play for point in VO which
is a uses a physical gun and then lastly
I went to check out full honour because
I didn't play that last year and I've
been very curious about it but
unfortunately I couldn't really play it
I tried of course but because I still
have tendinitis I have a video about it
I'll link it below um there are certain
games that I can't play because it
physically hurts me a lot and for on it
was one of those honestly wasn't super
impressed by it anyway though right now
I'm in the hotel room I'm in bed I did
not make it through today very well
because of the IGN party last night
mostly so I'm taking a nap before we
have our content team is doing like a
cool dinner thing so everyone who's been
walking on different stuff at e3 is
going to get together and have dinner
later tonight there are some parties and
other stuff that we could do tonight but
I am so tired that I don't think I'm
going to make it it was an awesome e3
though I didn't really put a whole lot
of my impressions of games in this video
because this was supposed to be more
about the processes of e3 than about the
games that I played on my opinions on
them but at the start of July I'll do a
June wrap-up video and I'll talk about
um some of my favorite games that I
played at e3 then so until then I'm
Alana thank you guys for watching I'm
gonna take a nap goodbye